hey all attended couch here and this tie
Tuesday video we're actually not gonna
look at the this week's data set again I
know I've been kind of deviating away
from these weekly data sets but I found
that a lot of you guys want to do a lot
of Tidy model stuff and I thought be
interesting to kind of go over a book
that I've been reading in the past week
called feature engineering and selection
a practical approach for predictive
models in max Kuhn actually I guess I
co-wrote this uh this book and it's
actually this is the successor to apply
predictive modeling which is a machine
learning book which let me grab it which
is this book right here that I read last
last summer and it really taught me a
lot about machine learning Max Koon also
is a pretty busy guy and yeah he's
working on the he's on the tidy models
project too so I figured that since I
kind of have taught basically kind of
the the the model procedures of apply
predictive modeling and the tidy
framework I thought we should go more in
depth into more feature engineering I
think what two weeks ago we did some
feature engineering stuff specifically
amputation center and scaling and that
kind of stuff but we didn't really do
any any any advanced feature engineering
so with this book I actually was reading
um let's see here the the interaction
effect section and I thought that'd be a
pretty useful thing to do because once
we already have these centering and
scaling and PCA and always a linear
combination stuff we should actually
kind of look into some actual analytics
and kind of Science in statistics into
these actual models so I think for this
this video I'm gonna basically center
around interaction effects and how to
create them in the tidy models framework
will also do it in the linear model or
the besar section but for right now
we're gonna do it in tidy models so
what's low cup AR markdown
one up use a document make this
fullscreen I'm gonna assume this in a
little bit there we go okay um and we're
actually gonna use a decent amount of
packages but we're not gonna do a lot of
data visualizations and I'm gonna try to
make this a little quicker but we should
be still learning a few things so let's
do the tidy models package the tidy
verse and also this package called the
Ames housing package and what's cool
about the Ames housing package is it's
essentially like I was it make it's
essentially just a data set so we're
just gonna do that call us the Ames data
Ames datum cool so we look at Ames data
Ames data we can see that there's a lot
of columns and a lotta rose there's
about three thousand rows and eighty-one
columns which actually means it's a
pretty it's a pretty wide data set it's
not one of these toy data sets well it
is a toy data set but it's not one those
toy data sets like I got iris right
where we can kind of easily visualize it
this will actually take a lot of time to
visualize it and we can kind of see
there's a decent amount of factors right
or a bunch of categorical variables
there's a you know there's a few uh I
guess numerical data and that what-what
I also notice is okay so much I have
scales too right so we have a bunch of
like ones and twos and also 1600s and
the main thing between oh and we also
have longitude latitude data so we have
like geospatial stuff but the main thing
that we want to look at for this dataset
is sale price rushing me using tidy
models to predict sales price so let's
just look at the distribution of it so
sales price so
price and I was just to a ggplot sale
price and then let's do a histogram
let's do a histogram first oh let's do a
sigh pen first oops options Sipan equals
$9.99 cool so let's look at it so what
is the median price is about two hundred
thousand like less than two hundred
thousand dollars that makes sense I
actually lived in Ames for a year when I
was at Iowa State I think I mentioned
that before and you know all those
houses are not too expensive but we can
see it's kind of sitting around there
okay so I'm not sure gonna do a crazy
exploratory analysis on stuff on the
stuff I've actually kind of looked at
this data set beforehand
kind of prepares less than our video so
we think about interaction effects like
what what our interaction effects right
and the main idea between interaction
effects is that the that when held equal
they contribute something to explain
some type of variance however what they
really do have is an interaction between
another feature so it's saying that when
one for your changes the other feature
is also affected and a good real-world
example that I believe is used in this
this book is the idea between like
saying we're gonna create a a model to
predict crop yield and one of the
features is rain and the other feature
is fertilizer so we know with crop yield
on when that rains pretty good for crops
right fertilize is pretty good of crops
but it would put fertilizer and we have
zero rain you can add as much fertilizer
as you want you're not gonna get a lot
of yield the same thing with rain if you
add a lot of rain there's gonna be some
diminishing returns without the
fertilizer so fertilizer and rain would
have an interaction effect when creating
a model to predict crop yield so let's
see if there's any interaction effects
in the Ames data okay so I know that
there's one interaction effect I'm just
gonna do it with it with its rollers
shipped his sale price so we're trying
think what interactions do we think
would affect sale price one of the
interactions that is used is the year
built in central air ok and for the for
the crop example that's actually using
continuous variables and actually
continuous variables it's kind of hard
to visualize those type of relationships
you know if you think about how could
you visualize it so you couldn't do an
XY scatterplot it maybe you could do
excising too but the the easiest way to
do it is to compare the interaction
between a factor and a continuous
variable so that's what we're going to
do ggplot a yes x equals year built y
equals sale price color equals central
hair point smooth and since birth the
kind of thing about like will control
for these factors will just do a method
equals LM okay cool I'm gonna turn the
Alpha down alpha was it up or down 0.1
okay and we can see here so one main
thing with interaction effects
especially with these like was it
factors and continuous variables is a
how you can really tell if there's
appears to be an interaction or you know
that we're not getting a lot of causal
inference but we're seeing interactions
will generally have is kind of like
crossing where the slopes are different
a non interaction or if we think that
these values weren't interacting we kind
of see that they were parallel well
there'd be like no effect on sale price
whereas if we see with central air and
you're built we can see that they have
given slopes for the no central air it
kind of seems like it's almost zero
slope it's kind of thing stagnant
whereas the central air yes we can see
that it's actually increasing as as the
the home is newer
um let's actually look at it um
separately right so I'm gonna do that
I'm gonna select this
okay and we're just gonna do a ggplot oh
we do uh what's it okay gather gather
key equals key value equals value minus
sale price and then we do at ggplot yes
x equals value y equals sale price yeah
and I'm going to do a question oh
actually can't do that how can we do
this okay we'll just do that so your
bill and we'll just do that as a as a
function of ggplot yeah it actually goes
your pilled y equals sale price gym well
I'm okay we got that so we can see it's
kind of a scatter plot thing we can see
how as you're built as these houses are
getting younger their price can be a
little bit it's gonna be increasing and
if we look at the other one where we do
a select sale price and then we select
what was it central air ggplot AES x
equals central air y equals sale price
and now it's to a boxplot right we can
see how there there's definitely a
difference between the sale price we can
see how those difference right there and
then we can see the actual interactions
and how how no central air has a less of
an interaction than we actually would
have expected okay cool so now that we
have this type of stuff let's try to do
this in like an base R or just do the
base our first just to make it so we can
kind of get some intuition and just see
how easy it actually is so we can do
let's see here if we just do a linear
model where we want to predict sale
price oops
price and data equals Ames data
we can see that there's a lot of
features and not only that if we notice
the linear model
well actually automatically like change
change these factors into a into a dummy
variables right so we're gonna have to
think of something we're like okay well
we could do like was a tidy and kind of
get all this stuff and we can evaluate
our p-values you know we could say like
filter p-value is less than equal to
0.05 right we have 92 features and we
just do like all the interactions that
are statistically significant and you
start from there but I think what we
should kind of look at is what's what's
kind of look at look at them
individually so it's kind of select
first the continuous variables and then
we'll select the categorical variables
and create some models and figure out
which ones are statistically significant
combine them together and then let's
start counting out the interactions so
how we're gonna do that okay so I should
say this this seems like a lot of work
and might not pan out okay so let's do
that I say let's select the let's select
a numerical features first and create a
model because if you think about it we
could do all the interactions possible
all these pairwise interactions so if we
do aimes data call names we can see that
there's what 881 column names but if you
think 81-81 pairwise um features or like
81 combinations is actually a lot I
think I saw in 2/4 two formats like 81
minus n minus 1/2
you know it's it's like 80 like what
times it or something like that but
there's there's a lot of features it's
not like with the iris dataset where we
could just do oh yeah there's you know
there's what four features so we could
just do a simple model and calculate all
the pairwise combinations
um actually maybe me I'm gonna I'm gonna
all make all the pairwise combinations
just to show you how easy it is but how
honestly it's not a good idea to do it
so if we do that time is I think this
data equals iris right yeah and then we
can do what yeah okay species verge oh
yeah I think it'd be easier I just tied
it so it's calculating say you have ours
since we're trying to predict sepal
length is have sepal width pedaling
pedal with species since is dummied we
only map to other species and it has
sepal width times pedal length sepal
width times pedal with sepal width times
you know the colors and we have all
these combinations right um if you think
about it if we only had what is it
one two three four if we only had four
features and generate like essentially
fifteen features or I guess four eleven
ten more features that's kind of a lot
so we're not gonna do that that that
seems like a bad idea to do it so we're
not gonna do it so I'm gonna say can't
just generate all pairwise combinations
when there's there is a lot of features
okay so I'm going to do that okay so
let's do that
um let's let's find the numerical
features so we can do a select I think
we can do we needed you select if and
say s dot numeric alright you know
select all the numeric features one
thing that I found that we can you also
do is select and say where is dr. merek
and we can also do like sale price so we
need to select sale price first and then
where is numeric so now we have all
these things they're doing the same
thing but when we do the factored
variables we can kind of add
Elle price first and then do you say
where is that factor so that makes a
little bit cleaner so we can do that
where is that doctor right so we have on
all that stuff that's cool
okay so let's first do this first we'll
say I generate a model with only
numerical features up features okay so
we'll do that and we'll do a when your
model sale price data equals dots then
we do it tidy we can do a filter where
the p-value is less than equal to 0.05
just gonna make sure it's yep its point
of five and then we can do a select D
term cool and then we can say let's hear
a numerical features that we want to use
okay so now we have these guys if we now
we might we're gonna run into a problem
here if we do a linear model already
sale price well we do the same thing
right data equals dot tidy filter P dot
value is also equal to 0.05 if we look
at this this isn't great because it's
st. you see these things these are the
same column but since they made a dummy
variable we can't just select a term and
say oh we're gonna select these
variables right we kinda have to do some
cleaning so here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna say I'm gonna say rename if I
rename rename if is dot Factor dot funds
he cools and then we'll say paste I was
it paste dot and then the separation
will say separation is just that and
then snow it and then we'll give it will
basically vit this ending so we can tell
oh yeah here's the start of the actual
values from that column so we knew that
except equals boom let's see if that
worked there you go so now we have these
all of these factored variables or
factored column names has kind of like
this on this little um what's it point
that can say okay anything to the left
this is a is from this class or from
this call okay
so we're gonna do that cool so now we
have all of our all our features that we
once okay if you know that's like 85
features that's so that's a lot of
features but just know that
well this one is technique just one one
column right so we don't have to worry
about it too much and then what we can
do is we can just do some rather regular
expression so we'll say a term but we'll
say was it said we'll say select term
and we'll do like a mutate new term it
goes SCR or place all the string is a
term the pattern is we're gonna do it
escape that dot and then just do was it
that okay cool and this base says like
okay once we find this thing we're going
to go until the end and just replace it
with nothing cool and also I'm going to
change the new term in goes STR replace
was it new term and then we want to
remove this little little thing right
there I'm not sure if it actually will
matters but we're just going to remove
it okay
select new term okay okay so now that we
have our terms so I'm gonna give this
thing and call us I was a Kadett
categorical features cat it categorical
features okay journey oops
so generate a model with only
categorical features we have these
features right so now let's we can
you another little cool tidy select
thing we say Ames data select sale price
any of and we can say numerical features
we have to say was it term I mean I
selected all that right we can also I
think add another one any of and we
could say categorical features and then
was it new term cool so now I think we
have all that stuff yep good stuff and
what we're gonna call us is we'll call
us our let's call our our main effects
data so right now we're just trying to
create a main effects model so we're
just kind of make a baseline model with
no interaction effects but we did do a
lot of our reduction so we removed a lot
of features we didn't think we're gonna
be very useful for us and in this case
we used the p-value criteria so there's
actually some problems that we I think
we kind of did with the p-values for one
thing I think we might have standardized
them which is actually isn't too bad to
do only let me see if I can do a
standardization of it so if we do a we
can just do a I think what's it
summarized was a adjust what p-value ja
p value was it p value as dot p value I
think it's something I just thought he
adjust p value our feet up adjust P dot
adjust okay P dot okay that was really
annoying
okay so P dot I just so we can do it uh
P dot adjust and then we could p dot
value analyse a method equals false
discovery rate
right I knew we could say adjusted
p-value equals that all right so we have
our just p-value and then we could we
could do something else like that well I
think we can see it also dot those false
oh so that that's kind of how you you
know how to I'm sure there's like a a
thing with summarize function dumb
summarize let's see here
- summarize i mean question mark
summarize summarize dropping oh it's
it's I think key beetles true cool so we
can do up with a keep equals true I
don't know whatever there's probably a
function that you can you can keep it
okay so now that we have the main
effects data we can kind of move on and
do and start creating our interaction
effects okay so I think this is when
we're up shouldn't bring some tidy model
stuff
one thing that ooh actually one thing
that we can do though is uh let's see
how can it is is when we're creating our
interaction effects we could actually do
which is probably specify our main of
what which features are actual
categorical features and which ones are
numerical features so how we're gonna do
that let's see here main effects data
rename if a Zack knew Mary is that will
do is dot
marek dot funds equals and then we'll
say a paste a dot and then we'll say uh
dummy will say honest or dummy except
separation equals yeah
no no separation let's see if that
worked
oh is that is that is Dada was a factor
cool
then we can do rename if is dot numeric
dot dot funds equals paste um numeric
set equal 's and then was a rename sale
price equals 100 so I just Rumi are so
after sale price would be say would be
sale price on score numeric and now I
just changed the sale price so now
everything's kind of situated so I'm
gonna give that to the main effects data
cool okay so we can say specif created
data for modeling renamed those renamed
columns for each feature data type cool
so we'll start doing some tiny model
stuff okay this is where that's kind of
good I will say setup seed equals was it
2020 so 2020 and we'll just do will do a
main effects model and main effect an
initial model okay so so what's a main
oh it main split initial splits
main effects data prop equals point
eight now I think about it we didn't
have that we just use the same splits
right so let's just do that would say a
tidy split
ah wait yeah yeah tidy split tidy
trained Eagles training tie a splint
tidy test testing tidy test hope steady
tidy split cool and I'm gonna run that
just to make sure I do it so create
train and test splits create K folds
it's just great so tidy k-type tidy k
folds V fold CV tidy train I will keep
that okay I'm cool so we have our train
we have our data stuff get a basic bulk
at an interaction effect let's start
doing this
so yeah let's do it so let's create
first our main effects model main
effects recipe and this is one where we
just are not doing anything we're not
creating any interactions we're just
doing some basic some basic
pre-processing so we're just gonna do
that so data equals tidy train and we'll
say step was it dummy I would say all
nominal and then step oops SEP Center
and then we all predictors cool so we
have our main effects recipe nothing
going on too much we're just kind of
doing a center on all the variables
nothing too crazy so then let's do a
main
oh no to interaction let's do it let's
start doing our interaction effects so
create basic recipe for a main effects
model size baseline okay now let's say
create the interactions okay so let's do
a recipe a sale price date data equals
tidy trained step dummy all nominal and
now what we're gonna do is we kind of
have a problem that when I was looking
at interaction effects I actually didn't
kind I didn't really think about it
but while I was reading the book they
made it a point to say you generally
should create your interaction
interaction effects before you center in
scale okay piece that is you guys once
you Center in scale or center your data
it kind of loses all the actual
interaction effects between the
variables so we need to make sure to
create the interaction effects before
our step Center also one of the reasons
why we're not scaling is for some reason
I want to do step scale it messes with
the GLM net model that I'm gonna do in
the next section I'm not sure why but
it's fine if we just Center it so what's
but let's first start doing the
interactions so if you notice um since
we have our was it our main effects data
we have all these things where we have
like numeric and stuff like that and
then we also have our dummy ones and
since we ordered you're gonna just do is
we're gonna do the interactions purely
between um our factored and numerical
data and not just all the combinations
we can do some things that we use some
tidy tidy eval functions to help us make
these interactions so that's what we're
gonna we're gonna do step interact
and we give it a formula with a little
tilde and we'll say contains dummy and
then we're gonna be the colon as it
contains numeric cool and then what
we're gonna do is we're gonna say step
Center all predictors cool all right and
we'll say it will call us our
interaction effects recipe so if you
actually look at it if we do the
interaction effects recipe do a little
prep it kind of loads a little bit
because it's trying to calculate all the
interactions okay so we see all these
things and saying okay we're gonna take
all we're gonna create the dummy
variables we're gonna do the
interactions with all of these dummy
variables and compare it to I guess all
these numeric variables okay and then
we're gonna Center in scale Center it if
we do a bake and we'll just give it that
ID train and we give it the column names
we can kind of do a sanity check just to
make sure that it's working on it
technically I could have just did like a
head function right here and it would
probably want faster it's always here we
can see all of our numeric stuff we can
see how it created the dummy variable we
can keep on going down it's go here
let's see if there's an interaction set
and then we have our interaction right
here it's saying dummy once or 1945 and
older times the lot frontage cool
so we have our interactions let's see
let's do it can we do a andro
with the okay we can't oh oh I bet two
lengths just said and I'll do uh let's
do a head so now there's four thousand
eight hundred features that's a lot of
features and that's something where we
have more features than our actual
interaction samples and that's a big
problem that means that we really can't
use a linear regression right now so how
can we really reduce these interaction
effects when the main things from this
book is that when that idea is is
interaction effects only some
interaction effects will actually add
value to our model okay and the point is
our models really shouldn't have like
three thousand interaction effects in
reality I bet only about like five or
ten of them will actually add a lot of
value or there's like some type of
diminishing returns on to our exploit
variance in our model okay
so what we're gonna do is if we have a
lot of features and we want to remove
them well I
that always begs me to use is a lasso
regression model so that's what we're
gonna probably do okay so I'm gonna make
a comment say that's a lot of features
we will need to do some feature
elimination okay so let's create our
lasso model so let's create a Oso model
so lasso model model linear regression
Oh linear regression penalty since the
penalty will be tuning that but we know
that our mixture needs to be one make
sure equals one because make sure equals
one means it's a lasso regression so
we'll do set mode equals regression I
will do a set engine and that engine
will be GLM
one cool thing that I was kind of
looking at is we we don't actually have
to even define our parameters for our
tune grid so we can just say define
model parameters and we just say a lasso
info parameters and we can say lasso
model and that'll actually just give us
the things that we're gonna be changing
there's penalty cool okay so now let's
start creating our workflows so create
the workflows so first we're going to
say our main mix main wondering ago main
effects model main effects model
workflow so so we'll call this main WUF
workflow add recipe main effects recipe
and we'll say add model lasso model well
and we'll say interaction effects model
work well what goes into into workflow
workflow add recipe interaction effects
recipe add model and we're gonna give it
the same lasso model great so we're
gonna have our model workflow our models
on our model workflows now let's
actually start doing the tuning for
miles so we're gonna do a I would say
create a tune grid for the models and
since we're using the same models for
both of our workflows we can just use
the same grid so we're gonna create a
lasso grid and we'll say grid regular
and instead of saying like penalty we
just say we can just pass on the lasso
info which will give it the parameter so
we're going to change and we'll say
levels equals and let's see we'll give
it 15 15 different tuning parameters I'm
at 15 different types of
he's that we want to use for it cool
okay so now start tuning them so we'll
say tune models using grid search
so we'll say we'll do main the results
first in results egos tuned grid give it
the main workflow give it that resamples
which is D was it tidy K folds and give
it our grid our grid is equal to our
lasso grid and we're gonna do with the
other one too
I feel like there's a way to do to maybe
maybe do some things where it's more
automated but we only have to switch one
thing which makes me suspect that we can
do it but I'm not sure how to do it yet
so and and then we're gonna tune these
models okay let's hear what else we need
to and what's cool is when we pull up my
OneNote app what's cool with I took some
notes behind it and we can kind of go
over um oh yeah yeah yeah no okay sorry
about that um and basically some ways to
do there's some principles and one of
the main things that there are is the
hierarchy principle let me see it how do
i zoom in on this anyway how do i there
was a view up there so there's so
there's the hierarchy principle which is
a higher degree of interactions the less
likely the interaction will explain
variation so in this case we're doing a
little hierarchy on print uh and we're
doing a low degree of interactions we're
when we're doing a pairwise interaction
or with two features that's considered
I've got two degree I think interacts
well they're explaining what the race is
saying is that it's not realistic for
you to use like five-way interactions
where it's gonna be like lucky for
example if we're gonna go back towards
like the the the crop yield example it's
not gonna be an interaction between Sun
rain fertilizer you know humidity all
those together um it's probably not
gonna add that much value opposed to
having two different pairwise
interactions okay additionally there's
another things of effect sparsity so
they said okay we just read only some of
them will even if it's possible to use
them and you see that they're they're
available it probably won't it might not
actually explain it variations one of
the main things is the heredity
principle which means that which is the
idea of interacting terms must be
statistically significant okay there's
two different types of heredity
principles there's strong heredity which
means that if you're doing a pairwise
interaction both features need to be
statistically significant so we would
say like both of these features that we
use in our interact our pairwise
interaction must have P values lower
than 0.05 less than or equal to 0.05 a
week here right heredity means that only
one of them so if one of the features
needs to be statistically significant so
yeah so you can have one strong where
it's like the P values less than or
equal to 0.05 and the other one could
not be statistically significant since
we're really trying to reduce the amount
of features we have and the amount of
interactions we actually use a strong
heredity principle cool so we have all
these things we can do we can just find
out the main tune so we'd say main tune
I'm gonna actually I'm actually skipping
like okay let's do a model post hoc on
this stuff because we're actually using
this to kind of explain some things and
kind of go over these tighter workflows
that I haven't gone over so it would be
like oops so we can do a main tune and
we could say like main results
lect best and we probably want our MSE
as a metric so we'll say extract extract
a model parameter so we got our main
tune and we got our interaction tune
right so inte RS o and okay so we have
our tunes and every we can probably look
at our main tune in tune hmm so they
have basically the same penalty
parameters interesting okay additionally
what we can do is we can kind of create
our final workflow and it's something
where I've finally been kind of looking
at the workflows and slightly wrapping
my head around it so we're gonna do this
this is something that's pretty probably
gonna be useful especially when we're
doing these lasso regressions so we're
gonna do that so finalize the workflow
for modeling okay
so main workflow main workflow finalize
a work well and give it our final tune
and we can do our in work foil our int
workflow finalize workflow make into
tune if you notice I'm in the past
videos I was actually creating another
workflow the in here you can just assign
the final parameters to your actual work
your original work coil which is
actually very convenient so that's what
we're gonna now um we'll get our final
models so if we're gonna do that main
workflow I last fit me and split collect
metrics okay so we have a rue mean
squared error or three thousand three
thousand eight eight hundred ten okay
then we could do it in workflow and we
can do it and omein what's called what
we call it main split right
so get test metrics okay oh well
actually just said we're trying to do
sale price yeah okay
okay cool so we can see that there's
it's they're slightly different but what
we can do is now we do a comic a
post-hoc on our model because if we
actually get have a look at our work
well we see it okay it's doing when your
regression is just doing your dummy in
center using penalty of point zero zero
zero one mixture of one the door int
workflow it's doing the same thing it
says okay we're also adding an
interaction Yatta Yatta
nothing crazy okay but we can actually
do is we can extrude to do is extract
the model and kind of will get its
coefficients right so let's do that with
our first model so we're gonna do like a
post main model and we'll say pull a
workflow fit and we're gonna do the main
what's what's called oh yeah what I'm
doing sorry I totally got ahead of
myself well we have to do now
it actually create our final model so
we're gonna do that we're gonna say main
effects so now I want to say create our
final model since right now we just
created our workflow well we haven't
actually created a model yet so we're
gonna we're gonna say main effects model
I'm going to fit our main workflow with
our main effects data main effects data
and then we're going to do our
interaction effects model and I'm going
to fit that with our interaction
workflow and our main effects data okay
create our final models
so if you look at our main effect model
oops it's kind of just showing you our
workflow so we did a linear regression
dummy tail has a little thing great
that's not actually showing our cool
fish so we kind of have our tuning
parameters we don't have our
coefficients so we got to do is get our
pull we died pull our workflow fit okay
I mean that's what this would be our ara
our was it our make our post mein mop
main model and we look at our post main
model we can use the pluck option and
plug the fit we can also do the finally
use the coefficients thing but we will
get it there's actually 2 or 25
different coefficients
alright that's kind of a problem let me
see our culture just but with we kind of
don't know and what we don't
oh we don't want all these tuning
parameters right so we can do is we can
specify our coefficient with s equals
and we can specify our best tuned model
and this case we can use the was it the
main tune right main tune penalty
okay and we have all this stuff so now
let's actually look at our interaction
effects model so post let's do a post
interaction model pull workflow fits our
interaction effects model and then with
our post int model we'll do a pull
workflow interaction
oh no no no will do up pluck fit caliph
s equals was it interaction what do we
call it again
was it in tune that's what it is in tune
in tune with the penalty and what we see
here we see that it actually did
eliminate a lot of our features all
right so right now what we can do is we
can just do like was it a tidy right so
with the main effects model we have we
have so with oh so with the interaction
effects model we only have 250 six
features now but and then with the post
that with the actual main effects model
we have 224 so we did do a bunch of we
did do a bunch of reduction and feature
illumination or we did all but decent on
a feature selection with our loss or
regression model we shrunk our 4848
features to was it
356 so yeah this is basic this is kind
of a short quick video but I wanted to
do a something on interactions just so
you could do a bit more advanced feature
engineering I'm still getting a hang of
these workflows and always cool little
like pluck options pull workflow fit and
stuff like that
but I'm definitely getting better at
tidy models I definitely understand the
workflow now I'm using less variables
and in my environments less cluttered so
I'm sure I'll probably make another tidy
Mahalo video in the future until then
tidy on